you we've seen this in like SQL
generation or maybe this is a tactic we
can talk about today like we've seen it
like SQL generation okay have the model
generate a JSON object that can be
determined turned into a SQL query for
SVGs the TL draw guy was talking about
this at AI engineer last week have the
model generate a structured object that
it's good at writing that then
deterministic code can turn into an SVG
and I think have the model generate code
that then you can like bake it's like
creating different views of the same
thing. Um, and then once that's baked,
then you can deterministically execute
that code with a programming runtime.
Yeah. All right. Well, with that, let's
get started. Um, my name is Byov. This
is Dexter. We've been doing this every
week for the last few weeks now. Um,
it's been months. We started in March,
dude. Oh, wow. Yes. But we took a break,
so I don't know if that counts. The
break is where I define the line. Um,
okay. But regardless, uh, the whole
point of this these episodes with AI
that works is to talk about real
practical AI applications where we don't
just talk about highle stuff, but really
try and show the code behind how things
work. Uh, we've talked about a bunch of
things in the past from MCP servers with
10,000 plus tools to 12 factor agents by
Dexter all the way to human learn how to
use humans as tools and then just really
how to think about prompts. But today, I
think we want to do something that was
different. It's going to be a lot more
varied in conversation than our previous
conversations which are all about
focusing on one depth thing. Today we
want to talk about just prompting as a
whole. Nothing fancy, just plain old
prompting. And many of you
uh and actually Dexter, do you want to
give a little precursor while I get the
screen recording up? Well, I think like
many of the things that we end up
talking about, you can take like what is
a really simple problem that folks kind
of can look at and just say, "Oh, that's
solved." like like classification. It's
like, okay, I know how to pass the LM a
list of labels and get it to output one
of those labels with structured outputs
or something like that. And then you go
and you look under the hood and it's
like, oh, like actually there's a lot of
room where I thought the ceiling was of
like, okay, here's the techniques.
Here's how you do it. There's so much
more room to basically open up the box
and rip out all the wires and redo
everything and like engineer it to get
much better results. And I think like
the core of that is always prompting.
Um, and so I'm really excited today to
learn about both like just some basic
techniques framed in terms of certain
types of problems. Um, and and I think
today one of the things that it will be
cool is um, we're not going to talk as
much about like one big overarching
problem like we usually do. We're just
going to give you a grab bag of um small
tips and tricks that are reusable across
problem spaces and like lower level
advice that you can apply to lots of
problems. And I think hopefully uh if
folks are down, I think we put a thread
in in the Boundary Discord. Um if anyone
wants to share their prompts, uh the
most I've ever learned about prompt
engineering is showing Fib AI
applications that I've written and
having him roast my prompt and tell me
what we're doing wrong.
Um actually with that what I'll do is in
the thing in here I will actually just
post a link to this thread copy thread
and I'll post this in chat if uh anyone
wants they're welcome to post their
prompts that they want to share. This
will be recorded
um and like just post it on here. We'll
fix your prompts at the end and we'll
just show you how we would think about
them. Doesn't mean that they'll
necessarily get better. It might just
give you another technique or two. But
with that, let's go into the topic.
Cracking the prompting interview. I
think prompting is literally like
software engineering. And we're just
going to use the same techniques to do a
couple of things off the bat. So, let's
start off with a very common problem
that I always see, which is always the
first one that I'm going to talk about,
which is like labels.
And this I think the most common example
of this problem that I see is citations.
So, imagine that I have a prompt. My
prompt will have a bunch of text that I
refer to it in for the context of rag.
With the rag, I will have it give me
like the URL or something attached to it
and I will have a bunch of these
along the way. So I have like a URL with
some data and then I want to go get that
and somehow in my answer I want the LM
to give me out the URL.
Uh this is this a problem that I
resonates with this couple people. Does
anyone have ideas for how we could make
this better?
If not, we'll just go right into it. Uh,
if today's session is going to be Are
you gonna are you going to replace the
URL with a sentinel token?
Kind of. Yeah, exactly. Because what I
want is I want the answer that over here
to be an answer, but I want to include
the citations that that remap to that
specific thing. Now, the problem is, as
we all know, URLs can be really really
funky. like just the URL for this
Excalad draw is I don't know let me see
if I can share one um like if I go to
like I don't know the random browser
page I probably have something open
where' it go
sorry
if I just go to like for example our
YouTube channel let me just show some of
these videos the these URLs are
basically you I could have this as the
citation URL for my model and let's just
take a look at what it would mean for
the model to generate this.
Let's just go look at the tokenizer
because I think this is the most
important thing to think about if a
model can generate something accurately
or not. This is what the model has to
generate. There's a bunch of tokens. So
these tokens make sense. It can probably
do this. YouTube is a single token. A
YouTube is a single token. That's kind
of interesting actually. Um I learned
that today. Uh watch is a single token.
We're good. Question mark V is a single
token which also probably makes sense
because YouTube probably is a
predominant force in the tokenizer for
some reason. But everything else here
breaks down. This ends up and this is
there's like models can generate a
string. If you type in that string, you
say, "Hey, model make this string for
me." It's going to make it. But your
point is basically that like the more
tokens that you're asking the model to
generate accurately, the more kind of
effort it has to put on that and the the
less likely it's going to get it right.
Exactly. So in order for the model to
get this part of the URL correct
specifically, it has to generate 10
tokens perfectly. If we remove this
part, let's assume it'll get question
mark V correct. It has to get eight
tokens perfectly correct. If it messes
up in any of these, it becomes a useless
link.
So how can we change that? Well, we can
do something really, really simple. And
I will just use YouTube along the way.
And I'll write a basic prompt that does
this and tries to go about this.
Oops.
So, we're going to write a question new
file like uh labels.baml.
I'm going to have a function that's
going to say given uh like answer
question. I'm going to say here's a
question. I'm going to give it a list of
links
or content.
I'll say like this will have like a URL
which will be a string and then content
which will be a string and then
what we'll return here is some answer
and then citations
string array at definition
list of URLs
that are relevant. Okay.
Open AI GPT40.
Great.
And um ctx
output format.
Sorry, I'm on a live prompt, so I'm
going to try and be as fast as possible.
Full user question.
Okay. So output format is you're telling
it how to output the uh answer.
Exactly. And you're and you're putting
the output format and the relevant
content into the system prompt and then
we're putting the user the question of
the user prompt.
Exactly. So I'm going to do this. So now
this my prompt um and I will literally
just ask cursor to
generate me a test case for this rag use
case
use
resume.
They're all the same file. They're all
going to have a test case in them. I'm
going to move this use.l as uh
as a reference for how works. So, I'll
just have it generate a test case really
fast and then it'll just go do something
for me. But we can see how like um and
then this takes a little bit, but we can
see how like the model might struggle to
go do something. Great. Accept. Cool.
Let's go do this. Um, and oh man, are
you going to make these URLs really
freaking crazy and then uh see if we can
actually get the model to screw it up.
We're just going to use this.
So, this is one YouTube URL
and I will copy another YouTube URL from
a different video
and I will point this out. It's not even
a matter of like the model will screw
this up. It the the point here is it
doesn't matter if the model does this
perfectly or not. The point that matters
is the model might screw it up.
And if it screws it up, I have no
guarantee on this end. So there's small
things that I can do. So now that I have
some citation thing in here, I can do
something nice in my Python code to help
reduce some of these errors.
Oh, you can put like a guard. This is
from the eval thing. You can put a
runtime guard of like, hey, if it
outputs a URL that wasn't in our input
set, bounce it back and tell it to try
again. actually open just this one
folder really fast. Uh
that way it's gonna be a little bit
cleaner. There we go. Uh otherwise
Python versions don't work for monor
repos which is the worst sin that Python
have committed. We're getting there. I
think the uv.python stuff might actually
eventually fix it. I really hope so.
So one thing I can do is I can literally
just get the answer equals this and then
I can say like for URL in answer uh
answer citations I somehow assert that
the URL starts with this. I could like
build some small search. I could I could
assert that the URLs are actually in the
actual content array that comes in
there.
Um,
oh,
I got it. I'll I'll I'll get the link.
Um, so we can actually go build this
URL, right, for us. Now, we can actually
go further. The problem is right over
here, the URLs, as we saw, have a
problem with how the model is going to
generate them.
So, let's go fix that actually. And
let's say this is our actual URLs.
uh
from BAML client.types
import content. Cool. Now what I can do
here is instead of actually putting this
URL as is I could literally put a I
could first change this completely and
say what I actually want to do is I
won't list a return of citations. I will
actually list an index
index of the content.
And now that this returns an index of
the content, what I will do here is
literally just print this out. Content
loop.index0
content idx. And now my prompt looks
like this. Instead of actually dumping
the actual URL, I just say content idx00
0. I can actually put like dashes here
separators. I can put them beforehand
because that might actually better
content.
I can do this. Um, and now it's actually
called content content one content zero.
And now I just remove the idea of the
URL completely from the model. And the
model will not do this. And when I go
run this,
what we'll find is great, we get zero
and one because those are relevant
indexes. And like let's make up a third
one that doesn't matter.
Um,
Europe
is pretty cool and has great pasta
and ideally it shouldn't pick up the
right content. It should only pick up
zero and one. And now what I can do in
my code instead of doing it in the model
is I can convert the URL into the actual
citation. So now I can just say like
content of URL dot um what is it
contents of URL
URL or the actual URL that I actually
want. So it becomes an index based
lookup instead of a real one. So the
idea is you really don't you really want
to do your best to not rely on models
generating long sequences of tokens that
don't make sense for the model to
actually intuitively think about sim.
There's no meaning. There's no meaning
baked into that random string of
characters. It's just a pointer.
Exactly. And if you can go further and
if you go back to our content about
dynamic enums, you could, for example,
make this a dynamic enum that then has
an alias that gets mapped back to the
actual value. I was going to say we
could go into all of the fancy BAML
features that make this even easier. Um,
I'm going to say we are 20 minutes in.
So, if you if you want to move on to the
next tip or do you want to wrap this one
up or or do you have more on the label
stuff? Perfect.
It's don't use sequence of tokens that
don't make sense for the model. Go
update it on your own. We got one
question. Symbol simple tuning also
applies here. Exactly. Symbol tuning is
the exact same thing. Docs will cover
that. Can't talk about that right now
because of time constraints. We're going
to do another one. Diorization.
So, we've all seen diorization examples.
We're like, um, do this. Make a make a
transcript.
to diorization
diorization
function
use
labels of ammo as an example.
Do you want to do a quick uh whiteboard
on like what what do we mean by
diorization while it's working? Fine. I
will go do this. I'll describe some
words over here. So let's talk about
diorization.
Diorization. Diorization. Diorization is
this idea that we have audio coming in
and we want to turn the audio snippets
into like a
speaker plus transcript uh section. So
each of these will always have a speaker
and each of these will and then
transform into like who said what. So
the idea is most of these sequences come
from
and mo what most of these will do is
they'll basically say l literally say
speaker zero speaker one speaker zero
speaker one
um and you might actually want to go do
something more than that because you
might be having a conversation between a
nurse and a patient. So you might
actually want to say speaker one is a
nurse, speaker two is a patient and
transform your transcript to that. I'm
going to show you a prompting trip that
is going to reduce the amount of um text
that we might have to generate by an
order of magnitude to solve this
problem. Because if I want to go from
person one to
uh speaker, I like nurse
versus patient
versus like other cuz maybe their
husband or wife spoke up into it in the
middle of it. I want to know exactly who
these personas are. So, let's go do
that.
re real quick. Um, is there is does it
is I imagine this is probably equivalent
whether you're doing audio or raw just
like a raw transcript of a conversation,
right? Yes. So, I'm going to assume that
the transcript is going to have a
speaker. Uh, let's just say the
transcript is on, let's simplify this a
little bit. Let's say the transcript is
literally just a string.
And what I want to do is I want to
identify the speakers that exist for
each of these, right? So the transcript
is literally just going to be a string
and I I have um no other information
about it.
Uh transcript will turn into that. And
then what I want is I want to return a
di transcript which is going to be a
bunch of speaker segments. Don't need
this. And this will just have
speaker string uh text. And you might
even say that this is like nurse
doctor patient or other. Uh so let's
let's like write it like here.
Cool. Um,
identify identify the speakers
output format
and then
roll user.
Okay, cool. That's probably good enough.
Oh, that's actually pretty cool.
Um,
let's change this. But you actually just
want the raw text, right? Yeah. So I
will Oh yeah, that's true. Thank you for
identifying that, Dexter.
Actually, I think our test case is
converted correctly. Uh
are you I'm hurt.
My knee
hurts.
I'm sorry.
Sorry. So, so this is
already has the speakers identified
though, right? Like, but it doesn't tell
me who's who.
Okay. Is so would this technique work?
Like is this applicable also to just a
like non like if I just have a a stream
of text and I don't it's not already
split up by speaker.
I guess this Okay, so this just assumes
you have turn detection but not
necessarily um let's say we don't know
who the speaker is. We don't know
anything about this. What we really want
to do is we want to go and convert this
in a really quick way. Um so I'm going
to go change it's been hurting for three
days now. Uh fix um he's been
complaining about it for a while. So
this is interesting because there might
be a lot of other content here. So let's
just see firstly what the what the what
the raw thing ends up being.
Yeah. And cool. This this seems kind of
interesting. It's like cool. It has
other it has all these other things in
here. Let's try and make this better
really fast. Um and I'm going to combine
like two or three different of the
prompting tips right in one as I go. So,
the first thing I want to notice is,
hey, this is probably not very useful.
So, let's try and just like fix this.
Well, part of it is not useful. Well,
one, I'm outputting the whole transcript
over and over again. That sounds bad. I
see. Let's see if we can do this in a
slightly better way. Um, so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to say
dialogue
index int. So, I'm going to give it give
it the dialog index. And here, I'm just
going to like write this in my prompt
really fast so I don't have to think
about this. But, uh, the right way to do
this is honestly to just make this thing
an array.
H, sorry,
I love cursor. And we'll make this an
array. And now instead of dumping the
transcript out as we are, what we'll do
is we'll say for line and transcript
print out the line. And now what we'll
also say is this loop.index0
dialogue
this. We'll add an extra space in there
and then we'll add that in. So now this
is an assumption that the the script is
already an array or are we just
converting the script into an array like
well you can just split by you can just
split by I'm assuming if you have some
way have a speaker colon here you have a
way to convert this into an array of
some kind. Okay. Right. Yeah. I think I
think in yeah I think the questions that
a lot of people are asking is kind of
the like the real time actual speech to
text use case is you don't have those
like separators unless you're using like
a separate like turn detection model
basically. Yes, but most people should
be using a turn detection model. So I'm
assuming that you have that right now.
You're analyzing a transcript in post.
We can remove the speaker labels as well
so it's like a little bit more clear.
It's like we just have all the
statements that are literally speech to
text per line of some kind. I'm going to
go run this now. Now, you'll notice the
model's actually really really good at
just spitting out the dialogue index and
who the who the speaker is in each of
these scenarios. Oh, so it doesn't have
to reoutput the actual text itself.
Exactly. Order of magnit you can imagine
for long transcripts, this is an order
of magnitude
cheaper in terms of how much text it has
to output. And we can reduce this even
further and just like alias this to like
alias idx.
And then it'll be a lot shorter. And now
it's just now it's just outputting the
index in the speaker.
I'm a little curious what would happen
if you just put it all as one big
string. What do you mean? Oh, like like
if you didn't split them out. I imagine
it's probably not going to work as well.
But it it the reason that this works a
lot better is twofold. one I'm actually
telling the model what the index is. So
the model has to go back and say I'm
let's look at what the model does turn
by turn. It's going to in first output
idx0.
Then all it has to do is in its token
during the attention mechanism the model
goes back into its tokenizer. So it
literally will go back through all the
tokens and just say okay what tokens do
I want to look at? I want to look at
next zero. It's going to go and just say
okay I need to understand this part of
this this part of the segment. It's
easier for it to focus. So even though
it's a little redundant, it helps the
model be a little bit more focused on
its part. Now it's like, okay, what who
likely said this?
And then it's like and then it goes out
and starts spitting out the next token,
spits out idx. So at the point of idx,
now it says, oh, what's the next idx I
need? Oh, let me go back a couple tokens
here. It's like that was zero. I
probably need one next. We're reducing
the burden on the model. That's the main
that's the main leverage here. the model
at any point is able to do way less work
and then therefore output more. Does
that make sense, Dexter? Yeah, I got
you. Cool. Cool.
Now, the thing is we may not actually
know exactly who's talking here. Like
this other thing, we might have made a
bug and not actually introduced other.
And in this scenario, what we'll find is
likely the model
will do something just output to nurse.
it kind of hallucinated on its own. So
we can actually just add other as a
fallback. So we the model doesn't tend
to hallucinate. We want to prevent
hallucinations when possible. And we do
that by giving the model an out. That's
another and this is the same with all
the all the classifier examples that
that we talk about, right? is like
classify the things you know you are
good at classifying in the fastest,
cheapest, most efficient way and then
allow the model to have an escape hatch
in which case you'll handle it in a
different way either by sending it to a
human to classify or sending it to a
bigger smarter model or whatever it is.
Exactly. But now let's do another thing.
Let's do another thing. Clues. Let's add
some clues here. So I'm going to help
model things that I'm Exactly. So I'm
going to help the model think about what
it is. And it's literally just like
it's literally just dumping the text
here.
Um, and like this is not very useful.
Add description things that help
uh uh inference to
let's just add a little bit more
dialogue here and we'll see what it
does.
um
uh let's say uh
what uh might
uh relevant. So let's so we're noticing
that what it's doing is just outputting
all the clues but a lot of the times
it's kind of obvious who the speaker is.
So let's just do this only if not
obvious
uh list out facts that uh help us
um identify help us analyze yeah John's
suggesting deductive reasoning steps
which I think is gets a little towards
some of the stuff we've done in the past
around like structured reasoning stuff.
Oh, a speaker. Maybe I had a much better
test case pulled up earlier.
So, and now you're noticing over here
now something a lot more interesting.
It says speaker zero other because they
don't know yet. Speaker one uses
personal pronouns indicating injury.
That means that they're probably a
patient.
Speaking about the patient, so probably
other
along the way.
So, it's actually a lot more useful to
actually go do this. And now we can have
a lot more com confidence behind what's
happening. But it's also it's it's
gotten it's it's gotten worse at picking
the ones where it was the doctor. The
doctor the doctor and nurse are worse.
Yes. But that might be because when you
really think about it, doctor and nurse
are actually confusing because how does
it actually identify correctly between
the doctor and the nurse?
And we can go about this one more time.
And if we actually go look at this, if I
were to read this transcript, there is
no freaking way I as the human would
actually be able to know if it's
actually a doctor or pat doctor or not
without knowing how many people are in
the room.
Very true. I could be talking to my
brother. Exactly. Exactly. And that's
the point. This could be my uncle
talking
Uh so whenever some when you said doctor
and patient got nurse you're right we
intuitively felt that way but remember
the model has no context around this so
let's add some more cont sorry could you
go to so before you clear this out could
you go to the third index index number
two
yeah this this time it seems to have
gotten it because it's making
assumptions yeah yeah about it right
it's make but now it's taking more from
the prompt itself like the actual output
format Right. Exactly. It's literally
just like ah you're probably either a
doctor or a patient. Like there's no
there's no way around this. But now that
we forced the model to be like who uh if
not only if not obvious go list out
facts.
And in fact the obvious answer for
identifying speakers maybe other in all
scenarios.
And that's what I would do if I had I
would unlabel everything. But then I
would say, "Oh,
but now we know for sure that this one
is a patient because it has been
nonobviously stated."
But we can go further. We can make this
a little bit better.
There
there were four people in the room.
Doctor Josh,
uh, nurse
off
text
uh uh friend
unidentified.
So we can go do this because maybe for
my EMR I know exactly who visited
but I don't know I don't have any
information on the other person at all.
So now let's add this in here
and say for context.
And now let's let's run this.
And now what we find is that the model
gets a lot better.
Right? So you could you could look at
like if you want to do this for a random
event, you could go get the people off
the Google calendar event and just
inject that at the top be like here's
the people and here's their domains and
here's you know two sentences of deep
research about who this person is.
Exactly. And this this mechanism of how
we felt like it got more inaccurate and
might have diverted us from actually
exploring this prompt further is
actually important to understand why the
model did this. step back, rethink, and
remember that the model did this because
if I were to be completely objective,
show this to a random person and tell
them to identify speakers, they also
would likely pick other. If they had to
be like if the choice would be wrong or
be correct, I too would prefer to be not
wrong and just pick other because other
is never wrong.
Cool. Um, are we going to do triple back
takes today? I'll do that in a second.
That's tip number two where we use
diorization.
And I want to show one last ver variant
of this trick which is these clues.
So instead of outputting clues, we can
just do this description
uh as a precursor
to the comment.
As a precursor
comment to this field.
So sometimes we want
but we don't want it to do reasoning as
a data field. I don't want to deal with
that. I just want to like output
something and I want to show you what
happens here.
Um if this works
uh example. Okay. So this is getting
into like how do we how do we this is a
great leeway. This is like how do we get
the model to output busted JSON in a way
that like actually helps it get better
answers.
Like comments in JSON are technically
not valid.
Yeah. Let's see if I can force it to do
this. I have to actually read the prompt
and see what it's doing.
Uh
use
As
if
if not if speaker is ambiguous.
List relevant comments
to help narrow
help
narrow
down
uh
to help narrow down um the
use first.
Well,
I'm going to go run this and see what
the model does.
Okay, I can't get it to do it. Let me
try and put this out.
This is like the weirdest trick that
I've learned and
uh so not directly in the generated
output format but just in the prompt
and
use for and had
and then
accident.
Okay. So, you always tell me not to use
a few shot prompting.
I do
because this is more about the structure
of the response, not about the actual
like learning from examples basically.
Exactly. So, let's see if I can get the
model to output this. And sometimes I
can't. Sometimes the model doesn't
really listen. Um, and just dump that
info as another field. So, let's do
another last thing. prefix equals answer
with this. I noticed OpenAI has been
doing this.
Oh, where like I think for whatever
reason whenever you use the word JSON,
they trigger something special in the
prompt that goes to like some other
model or something
or like secretly turns on. Oh, there you
go. Yes, exactly.
And now the model's actually um uh
writing some more comments but it's
writing the comments be after um
if list relevant facts on speaker before
the speaker field
the reasoning before the output. Yeah.
Uh question. So the reason to do this is
to save the tokens on writing clue every
single time or it is it's not always
about that. It's just like the model
might just it's just another tool in
your toolbox for how you can get the
model to output what you want. Clues is
one way to do it.
But and you can also do the thing we do.
It's like put the reasoning at the top
and then dump the JSON. And it sounds
like this is just like, okay, if we want
really targeted reasoning on each field.
Exactly. And maybe like this is way more
token efficient than having it output a
bunch of extra JSON.
Exactly. And you'll notice you saw me
iterate a little bit on this prompt over
here. Like I did a couple of things to
go do this, but this goes into the very
next tip that I want to really talk
about, which is one,
it's called RTFP. Um, for those of you
that don't know RTFM, it means read the
manual. RTFP means read the
prompt. Um, and I say that with
a lot of love because most people don't
actually read the prompt. And you saw
what I did when this didn't work over
here. I just read the prompt. I was
like, "Oh, the if I go back to the add
description mechanism, let me give you a
little bit more of a description of why
I didn't like this."
When I go read this, I'm like, "Oh, this
thing over here. Maybe it's getting
confused by the double comments.
And you can see how that might be
confusing to the model. So since I'm
using comments like nested comments in
comments, I'm like, okay, let me just
try and simplify this problem for the
model and give it that in a place where
it can't be confused. And that was the
intuition that I had out here.
Um, so it really just boils down to
reading the prompt because if we can
read the prompt, then we can see what
the model might be doing. And of course,
we can never actually know what's
actually happening,
but it allows us to actually know what
it allows us to iterate a little bit
faster and then we can say, "Oh, that
isn't working. Let me go fix that."
There's a question about why not use fot
prompting. There's a couple reasons.
Typically, the way to have done fot
prompting in this example would have
been me to actually go and write an
example and then write out the answer.
But that's not what I wanted. I just
wanted the model to understand that it
has the ability to go do this. it has
the ability to list out facts before it
actually spits out the speaker field. So
I just wanted to give it the structure
so it understands the thing it has to
mimic. I don't it's not the
Go ahead, Dexter. Yeah. And and all this
is again is like okay cool like yeah
probably just outputting JSON is good
enough. Outputting reasoning first is a
little bit better. Having reasoning in
your JSON fields is probably a little
bit better. But if you're running this
kind of thing a h 100,000 times a day,
then a tiny half a percent improvement
either in efficiency or in speed or in
token efficiency or in accuracy is
massively valuable. And this is what we
talk about every week on this show like
how do you how do you unlock those like
near the top of the accuracy range? How
do you push things even further? Yeah.
How do you get another half a percent?
And this isn't again remember this isn't
say that this technique will work always
but it is another technique that you
have available to yourself just like we
use this other technique to not spit out
the entire dialogue but rather only spit
out the index
and we use this other technique to say
oh dialogue index is actually a lot more
tokens let's use purely the word index
instead so it spits out the output
tokens are way less
it's small things that can make a
difference and And if I actually were to
look at this, my hunch actually says
index itself. Where'd it go? Index is
probably wrong. I should actually
probably use like index
because this is just a more popular
token that the model will have
understandings of or rather than idx.
Even though idx is a single token, it's
just more commonly understood
existing processes. Um, cool.
Question. Quick question. So we do this
actually hundreds and thousands of times
a day where we put out um um reasoning
and we use the reasoning as um eval um
for another model. So is there a way to
achieve or make it a bit more efficient.
Um so we literally spit out clues and
these are at least a a long sentence.
Um, so any any tips or tricks to make it
more One way is like if you really
wanted if you really wanted like um uh
if you really wanted that I would
actually put your reasoning afterwards
like assessment.
So if you want to do an eval thing right
over here description
final assessment
of the speaker
uh given any clues prior uh clues in
comments
I just do this
um and just like let the model spit it
out. Now you can use assessment as a
thing. But now you'll see that
assessment is actually kind of big. So
what I'll do is like use phrases
uh not complete sentences. And then I
would also add into here.
So now I'll notice over here what it's
doing and it will just spit something
out. And I would probably have to tweak
this model. So sometimes GT4 is not very
good. So let me try anthropic.
Is that the right model? We'll find out.
Oh, that is not the right model. Uh
dude, I think it's 1020.
Uh 2024 1020.
Custom Sonic. There you go.
Oh, I don't have an API key. One second.
Um I will not be sharing my API key this
time around.
Oh, that's why I come here every week.
It's because you always you always leak
at least one key. I also forget to
deactivate it.
Um
okay,
let me um
yeah, and just uh answering while he's
doing that, answering the question from
the thread. Um
uh why not use fuchsia prompting? Um, we
talked about this a little bit, but um,
it's basically uh, the content of the
examples uh, tends to greatly steer the
model's response.
And
so like you can get you can get the
right structural results without
actually putting content in your
examples.
Yes. Um, so there we go. Uh so now you
can see over here when I switch this
cloud I actually get really nice things
where it's assessment comes with this
and now you could plug this into your
evals. We got a way less tokens out
here. It's way it's way shorter
u because we're not using complete
sentences. So if you really care about
evals and want to like you want to store
the data anyway go do that. But honestly
if it were up to me I wouldn't do any of
this eval stuff online. I would have a
separate process that pulls all my data
down and runs a separate eval including
the assessment for each of these
segments off the raw data itself and
just run a completely separate process.
It's going to be way cheaper, way faster
because don't add more latency to a
pipeline that has this. Each of these
things that you're generating here is
latency. So a very latency sensitive
pipeline generally for speech to text.
Cool.
Um cool. Let's talk about uh so at this
point we've covered labels. Don't use
UIDs. Don't use URLs. Use like indexes
whenever possible and remap them
programmatically to the right thing.
We've talked about diorization. Don't
emit the full transcript. Have the again
have the index have the model represent
something that is way better than the
full transcript. In this case, an index
of transcript. We've talked about using
inline comments to guide reasoning of
sorts. We've talked about read RTF.
Reading the prompt. Read it always,
especially when you get stuck. Instead
of trying to keep prompting more, just
keep reading it. We've talked about
fuchsia prompting with structure, not
with actual content, and how we can
leverage that along the way. And I think
the next thing I want to talk about is
something that we've mentioned a few
times. Um, but it's all about codegen.
So, I'm going to go ahead and pull up a
random uh
file. Hey, Webhub Anup here. Before you
move forward, I in my mind I'm still
confused about using this technique
where you somehow use ginger to get an
index on that array.
I
go ahead versus using symbol tuning
thing. So when to use
[Music]
Okay, so just for context, let me just
pull up a symbol example. So then I we
can just talk about it.
Um
uh I have symbol tuning right here. So
the idea of symbol tuning is I want to
do a classification example. I guess
I'll do this
symbol
tuning.
Uh, oops.
Okay. Uh, I have a classification
prompt. Instead of actually classifying
the prompt, I want the model to spit out
one of these categories. And I have a
couple different ways I can go do this.
Oh, that's interesting. Um, I have a
couple different ways that I can go do
this. But one of the ways is like
instead of the model actually spitting
out
um all of my um classes I can and
instead of actually writing like the
word refund in the prompt I can write
just the symbol K1 and when the model
runs this it will spit out K4 which then
gets remapped to account issue for me
automatically. The benefit of this
approach is the model again it's same
it's the exact same thing as a YouTube
URL thing where the model when it sees
the word account issue it associates
these tokens with something semantically
meaningful and what I want to do is my
meaning of an account issue is actually
encoded in my description way better
than natural you want to say zero
attention on the label name because
that's for the coders and the program
that's consuming this all attention on
the description so that I can control
exactly what the LM is going to output.
Exactly. Exactly. It's about reducing
the number of variability in the
problem. Dexter said it beautifully and
symbol tuning is a technique lets me do
this. The thing that we're talking about
with diorization where we output
um where we actually output like the
actual index here that's basically the
same thing. Instead of the model
outputting the actual text of the line,
it's outputting the index of the line in
the conversation.
And instead of letting the model infer
the index, because I could do that. I
don't actually have to write this. I
could just let the model infer the index
by writing something like this instead.
Just like a break. Yeah, model could
count. But why make the life harder for
the model? Like this is Yeah. Now you're
asking the model to count Are you
kidding me? That's terrifying. It's like
it's like uh you know when you do these
coding agents and you have like no line
numbers in the file versus every time
you give it to the model give it line
numbers and suddenly it can do these
edits way better. Right. Exactly. And it
this goes back to RTFP. If I if I read
this prompt even as a human I know
exactly what index this is without
having to spend any time about it.
But if I don't have these lines in there
that becomes a lot harder for me to go
do. And I think it's small things like
this that actually dramatically change
the quality uh of your outputs in a way
that I think um can make a huge
difference. So Anov, I hope I related uh
the questions uh across across the board
for the one of how simulting relates to
diorization and the examples. And I we
won't go into this today, I think, but
like again, take all the advice from the
evals chapter and like don't go just
applying all this stuff willy-nilly.
Like get a real set, understand what how
your performance is today. Try changing
these small things, you know, whether
it's like, oh, I found a bug from
production. Let me drop it in as a test
case and just change the prompt until I
fix this one without breaking all the
other ones. or even having a bigger eval
set which is like hey our accuracy is
84% and if I make this change and run
the exact same data through the pipeline
now it's 88%.
Exactly. Exactly.
Um
let's start with the last part code
genen. Um this is something we showed a
couple times and this is kind of
related.
Well yeah this directly leads from the
other one because it's again it's like
how do we get the model to create
invalid JSON for good? like how how can
by getting the model to create broken
JSON you can actually get way better
performance and we'll talk about like
why that works by looking like under the
hood at like samplers and stuff right
yeah let's do that that's actually a
good idea um so in this case I want some
code and I'll say uh a binary search
tree with actually no let's do this a
sorting algorithm
with merge sort All right, cool. That's
redundant. Um, so let's do this firstly.
And it's going to output this. And
again, if I have a chat app, this is
excellent.
Um, this is really, really excellent. I
could show this to the user. They'll be
pretty happy. And we'll see the quality
of the code right here. It looks pretty
good. Uh, it has some comments and stuff
in it. It looks generally useful.
But the minute that this is the way
models want to write code by the way.
Like this is if you if you just want to
get the very best code performance, let
it write it between markdown back ticks
because that is what is the majority
present in the training set. Yeah. Now
I'm going to change this to actually
return a data model because hey, I want
the code so I can go find it. I don't
want to do some parsing. I want to
render it just the code part without all
those prefix or maybe I want to go run
it and go do something, right? You don't
want to have to write code to strip out
that like Python back tick thing cuz
you're just going to turn around and run
it. Maybe. And now we got this. And I
don't actually know the quality of this
code, but we'll see. All I do know is it
did output a lot of things. And I want
everyone to note something very, very
important here. This is actually what
the model output. This is raw. I just
copied directly the string the model
came out with. If I go back to the
tokenizer, I'll show you. I want to show
everyone what this means.
We can see what it did. Yo, slash and n
are two different tokens.
Yeah, exactly. So, it's actually
N. It's outputting a bunch of space
characters. It's It's not actually
outputting code. It's outputting
something slightly different. It's
something that looks like code. Will you
Sorry. Can I screenshot that and then
can you drop the other output into the
tokenizer as well? Sorry. Pop back and
let me get a screenshot real quick.
Yeah, I'll put it side by side. How
about that? Okay. Yeah.
Because I think this is really
important.
Okay.
So, if you get rid of the back ticks and
the actual like preamble and stuff, how
do the tokens compare? I'll I'll leave
that in there actually. Okay. Uh because
I think it's important. And this one has
like a Java example as well. So, why
don't I get rid of the Java example?
Yeah. uh just to like keep it in. Um
there's something in here.
And this seems to have a print example
as well. So we leave that in there. What
we'll notice here is not it's not really
about the token counter in the O. What's
really important here is like the
quality of the code that's being
generated. First thing that we notice up
front is recursively sort both halves.
So this comes out and then if we go look
at this all these backslash ends are
actually having to be forcefully
generated by the model to be correctly
syntactical JSON out of here because you
can't have new lines in JSON. You have
to have escaped new lines. Exactly.
Instead of letting the model just do
escape new lines. So what if we just
told the model to go do that instead?
What we'll find is code description use
use triple use back tick use triple back
ticks to format code
Python.
Now let's go read the prompt. Let's see
what the prompt looks like. This is what
the prompt looks like. Use triple back
to read the prompt.
Um,
and now when I go run this, what I get
is the model will output code exactly
how it was outputting before,
but in a way that still allows me to do
structured prompting. So this is not
valid JSON. And like the subtle thing
here is like and this is kind of like I
think we were having a conversation
yesterday about like one of the cool
things you can do with BAML and why
having a parser that is separate from
the that is outside of the model itself
is really powerful is because you can
let the model use regular new lines and
it's output and then turn them back into
J like regular like JSON that works.
Yes. Um so now let's go do this. Now I
want to make this as a lesson plan for
the following input as a lesson with
diffs.
So now what I'm going to do is I'm going
to output an array of code snippets,
not one
but multiple arrays. And then I'm going
to say make a plan um to for to go do
this example
section one blah blah blah section two
blah blah blah blah blah. Cool.
And again, we're using Fuse Shop the
example of using comments as guiding
principles. We're going to do the same
thing here. Uh, and then we'll add a
little title here. String.
Um, this is funny. This is what I
actually did for a workshop a couple
weeks ago was we had said, "Hey, here's
the final product. Output it as sections
in a lesson plan."
So, now we're going to do the same
thing.
And now what the model is I'm fixing
this bug. I mean this is cool but uh why
why would you want to do it this way?
Why would you want to do this? I guess
I'll show you the output because I think
the output will make it more clear. So
the first thing is I wanted to build a
lesson plan of so I did reasoning for
like what lesson plan I wanted to go do.
So it said we're going to go do this.
Then it's going to actually output the
code and create a merge function that
combines two sorted arrays. Great.
Create a basic merge sort function with
recursion. So it's actually incrementing
it. Now you can imagine that I walk
someone through the code one by one,
right? And now it's intending create a
sort with array splitting recursive
calls. So now it's incrementally going
to do this. Now I can build a UI on top
of this that literally has step one,
step two, step three and teach someone
merge sort with this benefit along the
way,
right? And along the whole time, if I
get rid of this section, I will I will
literally just comment this part out.
I'll show you how much harder it becomes
for the model to actually generate this.
like this is now like uh becoming
significantly harder for the model to
actually keep track of its own code
because even as a developer this would
be very very hard for me to even unread
and understand this and most of the
training data in the model's codegen
doesn't actually have backslash ends as
this. It has it as the actual back
slashn. So the code quality that you're
getting is going to be way worse. So
when we go to like a harder problem,
let's go into a harder problem because
merge sort is something that we all know
like even the basic models can go do.
Um create a what is it? What's a harder
problem next? Uh Kubernetes operator to
spin up RDS instances in Golang.
To spin up RDS spin up Yeah. instances
in Golang.
I have no idea.
I have no idea what half those words
mean because sadly I work in algorithms
land. Um, and we're seeing what the
model did. So, I want you to Oh, it made
a diff. Yeah, model made a diff. I also
want us to notice a couple other things.
The model actually intuitively just put
out back tick new lines anyway. It
actually was like, you know what? I am
not going to put out backslash ends. I'm
just going to spit out this. So, the
model intuitively did this for us.
without us even having to prompt it at
that. And that just goes to show that
the model's intuitive behavior
is not to spit out
uh escaped JSON. And the reason it
probably did this is because Go is just
a lot more technical than Python or
TypeScript and other things. So the
minute it got to like a hard mode
problem, it did the most basic things
for itself.
Yeah. Um, you want to pop back to the
whiteboard for really quick and just
highlight I I I want to highlight the
sampling part of this. Um, you have it
too. Yeah. Yeah.
Um,
there you go. So, okay. So, you got that
up. Scroll down a little bit. Um so
basically like if if if you know how
samplers work essentially you have um at
any given point you have you know the
model is writing code and it's writing
like you know code import OS and then at
any given point it's it's we're at let's
say we're right here and we're
generating like the we're asking what's
the next token at this moment there is
you know an a distribution of what the
next token's going to be right and in
this case It's almost always going to be
like new line, kind of classic new line,
and then there's going to be a long tail
of other characters that might be next,
right? You might have, you know,
semicolon here.
Um, because maybe some code has like
import OS, semicolon, and then another
import. Maybe if it's red code
serialized in JSON, maybe there is a
backslash here which is going to lead it
to correctly type the slashn. And maybe
there's some other characters here
defined by your temperature, right, of
like different probabilities of that
that's the next token. Does this make
sense? Yep. So when you put on strict
mode or strict JSON mode, and even in
some of the more like old school
function calling modes, they're starting
to enforce this. Basically,
that is going to when the model gets to
its like time to do the correct output,
it's just going to X out anything that
would break the JSON schema. Which means
that a new line is not a valid character
because a new line is not valid JSON.
And this is why when people say like uh
you know using strict mode reduces the
accuracy of your outputs, it's because
now you're removing the big one and you
have a very very like tight distribution
of the other things. Now these
probabilities get balanced out and you
have a bunch of things that are like
probably next but like not clear. And so
you're likely to get weird janky code
with like semicolons in it instead of
backslashes or even like invalid syntax
because you're not letting the model
write code in the way that it's been
trained to write code. Yeah. And this
applies not just for codegen, but it
applies to any domain where anytime
you're having the model not pick its
best token. You're basically telling the
model you know better than the model,
which may be true in some scenarios. I
want to articulate that. But most of the
time in machine learning, what we've
learned is let the model do what it does
best. and just let it output the best
token. Uh and in computer vision we had
this problem all the time where we'd
always let the model like we trying to
be very clever about the model where we
do oh let's do this pre-processing let's
do this post-processing it turned out
the best answer as all the VLM have
showed is literally just give it all to
the model let it decide and I think the
same thing is true with token generation
or everything else too like don't try
and be clever with token generation just
let the model pick the best token
um I think that's all we have time for
today in terms of actual topics and
prompting techniques techniques. Um, I
hope that this was incredibly useful for
everyone else. Um, what we'll do for the
next 15 20 minutes is I'll go to the
Discord and I'll see what prompts that
we have submitted, if we have any at
all. And there's a couple in here. Oh,
there are. Oh, that's actually more than
I expected. All right. Uh, there's two.
Exact. That's more than I expected. Um,
what I will do here is I will go do
this. Uh, let's just bring this one up.
I use this prompt to evaluate LMS on
their ability to make sense of LM
generated uh events. But before we go
into this, does anyone have questions
while I go read this prompt that people
want to go ask for? Feel free to come
off mute and just ask if you after you
raise your hand and um come on in.
So I do have a question about that code
gen
because like when we're talk I do agree
that like letting the code gen do its
thing is much better uh and produces a
lot better results. But on the other
hand um like when you're working in an
established codebase usually it has its
own like style and things like that. Um,
how do you resolve that problem?
Yeah, my uh Dex might have his own
opinions. My answer for all of that is
always the same thing, which is just add
more software on top of it. If you want
stuff to be formatted in a good way,
literally just run a llinter on the
generated code. It will be formatted
exactly how you want it to be formatted.
If you don't have a llinter with an
opinionated formatting, it's probably
not mimicking that. If you if you feel
like you don't have the llinter rules,
go write a quick LM prompt to look at
your existing code, generate lint rules
off of that, and then go run the
formatter. Um, but oh, because what I've
seen in coding agents is a lot of like,
okay, cool, read a couple like the like
using cloud code or something, it reads
a couple files and then what it's read
in the codebase already kind of
propagates down to the next code it
generates. But it almost sounds like
what would be much more efficient would
be like take a couple of the files and
have the model generate either like
hardcore lint because not all style can
be enforced by a llinter, right? The
llinters are getting better but not
everything. But like either create a
biome rule set or an eslint rule set or
whatever it is or even just create a
prompt that is like here's a bunch of
examples of how we write code that so
the model doesn't have to read entire
files but you capture it succinctly.
Exactly. Yeah. And like do a little bit
of extra leg work to find the models
that represent it. And I think this is
the same way if you think about like
just hiring a new developer. There's
ways to build your dev team where you're
like ah people on my dev team will just
figure out some coding format and
alignment. But if you really care about
code quality and want it to be
consistent then you add a llinter. You
add a formatter and then it becomes
uniform automatically. So like and the
most ultimate way to do this is to end
up using some language like go which
like forces like if you want to export
things that has to be capital like
developers don't even get a choice or
use black which is like a very
opinionated python formatter which says
no configuration it's just the way it is
and I think the same things apply for
like stylistic guidelines.
Um does that make sense?
Uh yeah I think um there's also like in
cursor for example there are also cursor
rules. Um, yeah. Uh, which I think also
help with this. Although I haven't
really explored a lot of cursor rules.
Yeah. Yeah. Cursor rules are a great way
to go do that as well. But I think like
if you're building an app that generates
code, then you can't use cursor rules.
So then you have to build your own
equivalent of cursor rules.
Um, that's really if you're using
cursor, then cursor rules should
hopefully just fix that for you. Why
cursor does this since cursor has built
a system like this. They basically added
a lot of software on top of their
codegen to make their codegen more in
line with your codebase.
Cool. That makes sense.
All right. Thank you. All right. Thanks,
Jonathan. Uh, one last question and then
I'm going to go into this prompt now
that I've actually read it.
Cool. Going once, going twice. All
right. Hack night at GitHub. Okay. So,
this was a prompt where it seems to be
like someone wants to look at an LM and
come up with like some sort of like a
plan for the most of this event. I mean,
it looks like the the prompt is
basically come up with a plan and the
rest of it is just input context, right?
Yeah, exactly. So, the first thing I'll
notice is like let's just go back and
write this prompt.
Um, and actually, oh yeah, plan.baml
family
function make event. Well, actually, I'm
not gonna actually do this. I don't want
this,
[Laughter]
right?
And this thing will uh make uh this a
better function.
Okay. So, the first thing I'll notice
about this is Oh, what the heck? Did I
not pay? Oh, that's so funny. We have a
bug. We have a
That's so funny. We have a bug where uh
com is it come as like markdown front
matter or something. It's like d-
comments. I think we strip it out. Uh
that's so funny.
Um fascinating. So like the first thing
when it comes to So let's let's catch
everyone else on what this prompt is.
This prompt is pretty simple. does come
up with a plan to make the most of this
event and then you dump the actual event
from like Luma or something else out
there. Now, the most intuitive way is to
just send that to the prompt and like we
send the chat GPT it will go do
something. So, like if I have this, by
the way, if whoever wrote that prompt is
is here, feel free to come off mute and
give a little more context around what
this is and what you use it for. Yeah.
Um, so I'm the one who posted it. This
is how I, you know, Luma has like a
hundred events a month in San Francisco
and I don't read them all manually at
first. So I use something like this to
try to surface the ones I want to go to.
And this is how I found out about BAML.
So you know, a pretty crude version
works for me and I just want to make it
a little more comprehensive, systemic,
and all that. And you know, I just don't
have an actual process for it, but I
know it kind of it works for me to make
the sense of San Francisco tech scene.
And I think I could do more with it.
Yeah. So over here you can see what it
come up with. And this is typically what
you'd expect out of this sort of thing.
That said, what I actually want is and
this is step number one. Literally just
stop asking the model to actually go do
like spit out the plan as a string. Have
the model actually spit out a
preparation sub for you of like what to
go do. And when you actually go do this,
let's actually paste. I'll just copy and
paste this in myself.
I think I copied and pasted this example
as well. So, I'll make this a test case.
Uh, I like the Discord only let you copy
one time. I know. That's so funny.
Cool.
Great. So, I have this test case now.
And when I go run this, instead of the
model actually spitting this stuff up
here, it's actually giving me something
a little bit better of like what I can
go talk to. And in this case, I have a
way better experience of like who I
actually should go meet. I can make this
more targeted by simply just changing my
schema class networking
uh
uh class networking
opportunity.
Okay. name
season
value
uh value high medium low description how
valuable
how yeah we we'll push all this code
John the person
is to myself
and my career
goals yeah the other thing I think would
benefit a lot here is like a lot more
context about me and who I am although I
guess if you're probably pasting this
into chat GPT, then you have your memory
and stuff at play to kind of like give
that grounding. So the main thing that
you'll notice here is I I'm actually
going to change this. I'm going to make
this a lot better. I'm going to say that
this is I want to meet these people
value and then it's going to dump out
the reason for why. And you notice that
actually changed out a lot of the more
general generally specific ones. Like
this was very
like random, but this is a lot more
pointed oriented. I can go act on this.
What else I can do here is I can say
like I can actually change this and like
entity
class
company type
company
name
class person
type
empty
equals this. And now when I go run this,
it should actually spit out what I
actually want. So now I can actually go
like specifically look these up and I
can build a small little UI around this,
like a React component that actually
renders these in with like LinkedIn
searches and follow-up sequences on top
of that. So then I can just go ahead and
say, "Oh, here's a link to the company's
URL. Here's who they are, and here's how
they are." And this is just like a IML
speakers. Cool. No one specific was
highlighted on there. So I don't
actually have like anyone ambiguous.
People are ambiguous there. But if you
put first name, last name, you could
also probably force it to like it. It
wouldn't even output that, right? Like
if you want to if you want to drive the
output to the point where it's like,
okay, I only want things that are
actually useful. I don't want this kind
of like hallucinating sloppy like talk
to a IML speakers. Like, okay, that's
Like I I only want like you to
pull out people with actual names. So I
was like, if there was a speaker name in
the description of like this person will
be speaking, then it could go tell you
some things about them.
And we can guarantee that at least the
first name or the last name exist and
then all other entities will just get
dropped.
So we still get these but then we they
actually just get dropped from our final
parsing because like it doesn't meet the
constraint that we need which is first
and last name need to actually exist. So
all even if that all generates it you
can drop it. But the whole point of this
is instead of actually having the model
spit out a string, what I really did is
I focused on what I care about, what I
want to see, and what I want to
personally derive out of this prompt,
which is I think what John, you're
trying to do is like see if things are
going to help you like grow out of these
events. So then I would just focus the
specific stuff on here to say like focus
on how it helps me and myself it is to
myself and my career goals. Yeah. Guide
the reasoning with as much context as
possible. And I bet if you took this
JSON object and dropped it into V 0, you
could make a nice UI for this in, you
know, 60 seconds. Oh yeah, I bet. Uh,
this is
same in line with this. make a UI for
I'll probably go do something
um and I'll go build some out some UI
for me and now we have a full app that
we can just go use directly without
thinking about it
with small little rendering stuff as
well. Come on, this takes a while. And
then you can do one more.
Uh, we got time for one more prompt.
I saw someone else typing in
or sorry, go ahead. Can I just drop the
prompt in the chat or should I? Uh,
it'll probably be too long, but you will
have to do it in the Discord sadly. Oh,
yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay, cool. Brashant
had another one as well that was uh
answering questions with like verbosity
and things like that. Yeah. So, so
actually you kind of answered many of
these in the previous example.
Yeah. Okay.
Um, and then we'll do the last one
really fast. Um, while we're out here
and let's while while Vzero is loading,
I hate this. I This is the part I hate
the most about Vzero. It takes so long.
Okay. While a lot of uh deterministic
code,
you are tasked with a video editing
plan. Okay.
I'm gonna This is sick. Okay, I'm just
gonna
do this. All right, so right over here,
by the way, we can see this.
So now it has a fun little UI for me to
go do build this in. Uh not to not to
edit, just to view the final outcome.
Oh, do you find the frowny face makes
Verscell make better content? No, I was
just annoyed that it did the wrong
thing.
Video. Uh, well, maybe if you went and
read your prompt.
That's Well, I can't read the visor
prompt. Um, so it's a little bit harder.
Um, insert script expert here. What is
this trying to do? Do you have your Do
you have your data models and everything
else on here?
If you don't, then I I can try, but it's
harder to do without like actual
function types because this prompt is a
little bit more complex. But let me just
give you some general guidelines that I
see right off this right off my right
off the top of my head when I read this
prompt. The first thing that I see is
I don't actually think you need all this
data. Like this is a lot more redundant.
you're uh I'm not sure if this is all a
system prompt or a user prompt, but when
I go look at this, the first thing that
I see is that this is not uh it's like
mixing and matching both the content and
the instructions all over the place
because like you're listing out your you
have instructions, content,
instructions, content, instructions,
instructions. It looks like more
content. Oh, that's uh this is the
output schema. Oh, this is the output
format. Yeah. So, it looks like you're
But then there's more instructions.
Yeah. It just feels like you're we're
mixing a lot of instructions and it
doesn't read um in the way that I would
write this if I were a human. And we're
also writing a lot of things. It's like
you are a blah blah blah blah blah. Like
the model doesn't care who it is. It
just has to know the job it wants to do.
You don't need to tell it this is my
role. If you notice in any of the
prompts, I didn't I didn't like I wasn't
like you're a senior engineer that does
blah blah blah blah blah. I just like
write the code um from this prompt.
That's like the first thing I would do.
So, let's just like there we go. And by
the way, for people generating this now,
you can generate this kind of UI
automatically from here. And this would
be super super easy for me to go code
gen. And then I could put buttons on
here that I'll call like enrich which
calls another LM function that finds all
the data about that company using like a
research thing that I go built. Sorry, I
context switch really fast.
Um, but let me go back really fast and
start a new chat thing.
Uh, make this prompt better and no XML.
Um, and the error markdown is the thing
that hopefully we'll fix in. Yeah,
Pashant the the you are we were just
talking about this before the episode
that like asking models to adopt a role
is uh I think I think the best prompt
engineers out there have been talking
for months about if not longer about how
that doesn't really work very well or
like it doesn't have that much effect on
the output. The funny thing is that um
uh this comes right out of uh clawed ROM
generation as well. Yeah,
I bet this just because there's a lot of
data in the training set doesn't mean
it's correct or good data. Yeah, just
like the most code out there is kind of
You probably shouldn't follow most
code. Uh but um a lot of code is still
very good and you should follow that,
but it's all about finding the right
segments. So in this case, the first
thing I do is like get rid of this.
Create a segmentation plan for the
following script. Break in logical for
each segment. Ensure it contains
complete thought or idea. Estimate a
reasonable time. Consider the pacing.
Um, and it's important to kind of like
describe what these mean because it
probably doesn't actually know and I I
have no idea what it actually means for
fast, slow, or medium. Like I'm just it
just made stuff up. You need to go and
actually understand your own uh thing
for that. Uh, and like if you you could
even force it in the schema, right? You
could be like, "Okay, cool. I know how
long this is and I can say I know I want
exactly, you know, do it in code and say
I want exactly 40 cuts because I want 30
to 40 cuts versus something else. I want
a
because then we're not making the model
count.
There you go. And instead of actually
outputting all the stuff,
I will actually just literally tell the
model to go do this. I will literally
tell it exactly what I want the pacing
to be. Instead of describing all the
pacings, I will specifically only emit
the pacing that's actually relevant to
the model. And that's the same thing.
The user and the program see a single
word fast, but then you translate that
into more verbose instructions, but only
the LM sees that part. And the LM is not
seeing everything else. So if I change
this from slow to fast, it sees this
one. Whereas in this one, it sees slow,
right? So now it's able to actually go
do this along the way. Um, and now when
I go, you can run it. Why not? Yeah, why
not?
And I don't even know what transition
is. Like if transitions have a separate
cut, like sure, let's do this.
Let's let's just run it this way.
and it's able to go do this. Now,
duration is kind of uh is kind of
misleading and the description is kind
of uh uh seconds. I'm going to change
this
uh
I don't think we need duration because
the duration is essentially the content.
So, we can skip it. Yes. But um you
might benefit from actually having uh
duration in there just so that a model
can like plan for each segment. It's the
same thing expected duration kind of
right cuz you have you have a thing in
there where you're thinking about uh
prompting but you want the model to also
be thinking about duration like the
amount of inference it has it's about
the amount caches why do we have a
reddis cache not because we can't go to
the database because we don't want to go
to the database all the time why are we
putting duration here so the model can
just like kind of think about this now
we see that this content is like pretty
uh short form which is totally fine but
if we want this be full content. Then we
can just do this. We can we can guide
the model to generating more text. Use
Well, I think your input test case is
really is really um small. I think this
is actually the right the right text
straight from the input thing. So like
we need like a way longer script to
really test this. Anyways, so drop in a
can I drop in a script? I have one.
Yeah, drop in a script. Yes, send a
script. Yeah.
yeah.
On the AI that works. There you
go. This proof of computing.
I like this. We should do this more. We
should uh we should take people's real
problems and solve them. Let's run it.
Right.
So, you can actually see what it did. It
actually spit out all the content as a
line,
but the duration seconds is 60 for
everything. No. Do you still want it to
be a list by Bob or do you want it just
be a single string? Uh, we can Oh,
sorry. Yes.
Estimated
seconds. Um, let's give it some
description like what how how do you
estimate duration?
Uh, let's say every 1,00 characters is
um a minute or 60 seconds or
something like that. Oh, are we going to
make the model count characters
every like let's try this a 1,00 every
uh so typically every 120 words per
minute so uh you can count words or
characters I don't know words per minute
uh what is average
right and we might actually find that
like hey if we do this it's actually
when we do slower pacing it's going to
be a little bit it's about 100 words per
minute.
If we do this, it's going to be like 120
and we do fast, it's going to be like
150. So, you might actually like find
that it's useful to actually guide the
model appropriately for the different
use cases because that's what I would
do. I would I would have a slightly talk
faster voice in general, not just like
the pacing.
It would be interesting to also have
this like start suggesting like, hey,
what do you want to show on the screen
during this cut? Right. Exactly. And
then you do like a image search and pull
that in um background image. So let's do
that.
This would be a fun building like an
example of this end to end of like how
to just like generate automated video
content from little scripts an end toend
content pipeline
to make you can come help me build my my
company. I was going to say yeah we have
to be careful not to build a open source
competitor to Sahill.
I would love for that.
Um uh a description
description
that is that is so I have a I have a
couple of questions over here. So
earlier in the example you were you were
showing how we can create indexes and to
to make sure that we are not spitting
out so much uh text and saving tokens. I
know like obviously this is a slightly
different case where we have to spit out
the text. Are there any tips or tricks
we could use to
do that index thing in here in any way,
shape or form? Well, I don't actually
know if you have to spit out the text in
form. Like honestly, you could just make
this a lookup table based on strings.
Like you just spit out every line, every
sentence into itself
as like a thing. And then you could have
the model spit out like a span
of like from dialog one to dialog 7 do
this dialog one to three and it'll
naturally find break points in the
dialogue and now you can go do that. You
can ask you can build a separate
pipeline that says if you really care
about like cost and latency I would
build a separate pipeline that says
given all these dialogues what is the
most intuitive break points to inject
into here and then you go generate the
background image and everything off of
that.
So you can solve this problem in many
different ways but it's more about
identifying the indexes of where the
break point should be for where
transition should happen.
Oh, so becomes similar to kind of almost
the diorization where maybe you just
wanted to output like the first like the
the biggest like the smallest unique
chunk that like offsets the text there.
Exactly. Exactly. Where would you go in
that?
Cool. Uh we're 90 minutes. We should
probably wrap it up. Uh this was super
fun y'all. Thank you so much Vib for
sharing your prompting wisdom. For those
of you who made it to the very end,
congrats. We'll uh there's no prize
except that you got to learn more. And
uh we will push all the code and the
video and we'll send out a blast and uh
come catch us next week and um we should
figure out what we're going to do next
week. We have a we have a we have a long
backlog of things, but we're going to
figure it out and we'll we'll we'll
update y'all with uh what's coming next.
So, thanks everybody.
Thanks. Awesome. Thanks y'all. See you.